okay um thanks everyone thanks to the
organizers for inviting me um
this is um another talk on uh bounding
the exponent matrix multiplication we've
seen a couple of those already and i'll
try to make some connections between
the material that you've already seen
and what i'm going to talk about um i
also should apologize at the beginning
to several of you who've seen some
version of this talk before i try to put
some new things in so i hope um
still some new stuff for you to see
um
okay so we're talking about multiplying
n by n matrices these have complex
entries as we know the standard method
is n cubed operations and stress and
showed that you can do better than that
we've heard that many times over in many
different
settings
the exponent of matrix multiplication
the smallest
number omega such that you can do matrix
multiplication and essentially enter the
omega operations and we're interested in
upper bounding that at least in this
talk we're interested in upper bounding
that other people might be interested in
lower bounds um
and then
so in terms of omega the standard
algorithm and stresses algorithm give
you these upper bounds on omega and
then there's a whole sequence of work
which we've heard um
bits and pieces um through a variety of
the talks in virginia's talk and james
hawk and others
culminating with the work of francois
legal who will also talk about
this afternoon so you have to get lots
of this in all different ways
what i'd like to do in this talk
is probably too many things for the talk
but i'll try um to give some of the main
ideas uh or the main ideas from the
original work up to the present work
only to make a point about a sort of a
common feature of the way those
algorithms and those upper bound
strategies seem to be working at least
it's my perspective on it
then i'd like to describe uh this other
approach via an embedding into
semi-simple algebra multiplication which
is joint with henry and a bunch of the
other people that were on the title
slide
and i'll work up by first talking about
groups and what we can do with groups
and then the latest generalization is to
association schemes and i'll try to say
something about what the advantages of
working in that setting are
um and um along the way i'll mention a
couple of conjectures that would imply
that the exponent is two that seemed
very natural to me and i hope that you
can
be excited about working on them perhaps
so that's the plan
uh okay so we know all about the matrix
multiplication tensor you can express it
in many different ways i'm going to use
again this notation which has been
common through several of the talks and
then n for n by n
square matrix multiplication it can be
expressed in this trilinear form where
the x y and z are formal variables
i just want to do the following picture
to sort of um situate us in terms of
some of the pictures i'm going to have
on the other slides so
since i'm a computer scientist and i'm
always sort of thinking about the
natural basis in which we're going to
talk about this tensor
and i'm always going to draw these
tensors in which i take the sl slices in
this z direction uh i'll just sort of
illustrate it in this way so here's the
two by two matrix multiplication here's
so the associated tensor is a four by
four by four tensor it has four slices
here are the four slices and if i label
the
rows and columns
with the entries of the a and the b
matrix you can see that each of the
the slices the entries represent give
you a
description of the bilinear form which
is the definition of the associated
entry of the result matrix so that's the
combination that gives you the c one one
entry and the next slice is the c one
two entry et cetera so those are the
four slices okay just to make things
concrete
and then in general we can talk about
rectangular matrix multiplication which
is represented by nmp the three
parameters
describing n by m by m by p matrix
multiplication again you have the
trilinear form where the indices match
up here's a picture of the
multiplication and each of the i didn't
draw out all the slices but each of the
np slices one for each of the result
entry
result entries of the result matrix has
this form if you organize if you label
things properly
so that the ones always occur on these
blocks along the diagonal these are n by
p
rectangles and in each slice the one is
in the corresponding position in each of
those blocks and it sort of marches
through all the possible positions as
you go through the np different slices
that's just to make things quite
concrete and to
treat us with respect to some of the
other diagrams i'll have on the slides
okay so as i said i'm going to talk
about strategies for upgrading the rank
of matrix multiplication tensor of which
we've seen several of them and i'll go
somewhat quickly through those but uh
and
again trying to make this point about
the common feature of them which is i
think in
contrast to the
strategy that involves embedding into
group algebras or
more general algebras
okay so here's the very first
observation that if you take the tensor
power of the of the matrix
multiplication tensor you get a larger
matrix multiplication 10 searching i'm
already went through that and so uh the
very first strategy imagine is to bound
the rank
of the matrix multiplication tensor for
small n by hand and of course that's
what stratton's algorithm does
and then already by the time we talk
about three by three matrix
multiplication we don't have a bound
that improves on the 2.81 in fact we
don't even know what the rank is it's
somewhere between 19 and 23 23 is the
best upper bound right now
and i just sort of throw this out i mean
so a lot of progress
has been made recently improving
coppersmith twin and red by small
amounts in with a computer search but if
you sort of take the sort of plain
vanilla computer search that you might
want to try to that you might imagine
trying to do to balance something like
this very small tensor rank uh even that
very small tensor uh sort of the number
of possibilities becomes um so large
that the computer switch isn't feasible
i mean if it weren't feasible i guess
we'd have an answer to that question
okay so you have to do something clever
if you're gonna do a computer search
um
border rank we've heard many things
about so the rank of a sequence of
tensors approaching the target tensor
entry wise uh here's
we have i think we've seen a couple of
examples that illustrate this here's a
very simple one that uh maybe the
simplest one that i know so here's a two
by two by two tensor those are the two
slices uh whose rank is three it's not
hard to prove that
uh but it's border rank is two uh and
you can see that if you allow this lower
corner to be a quantity that goes to
zero then you can express
uh those two slices as linear
combinations of these two slices with
epsilons in them
rank is two
so strategy two is down the border rank
for small
n
and we have this nice lemma due to
beanie
i guess
which says that the border rank if you
can prove a bound on the border rank of
n by n matrix multiplication of r
then the omega is bounded above by log
base n of r which is the exact
expression you would get if you had had
a bound just on rank and used the
standard stress and style recursion
so border rank is just as good as
ordinary rank for the purpose of
bounding the exponent of matrix
multiplication um and uh the example
that um jmrv talked about the border
rank of two by two by two by three
matrix multiplication can be shown to be
ten
and that gives you a bound of two 2.79
which is a little bit better than
strassen's bound
concept and of course it's
played a major role in all of the works
since that time
1999 i guess something like
that so strategy two
strategy three
find an upper bound on the
direct the on the rank of the direct sum
of a bunch of matrix multiplication
tensors so for example doing n by n
matrix multiplication in parallel with m
by m matrix multiplication if you want
to picture it you can imagine putting
the two tensors associated with n by n
matrix multiplication and m by matrix
multiplication sort of diagonally
opposed like this so that they're so
that they don't interfere with one
another if you want to think of it that
way
so if you can bound the border rank of
the direct sum of small matrix
multiplication tensors does that give
you anything for uh the exponent of
matrix multiplication the answer is yes
because of uh shown hunger's asymptotic
sum inequality this is a special case of
it for breakfast first
square matrices i'm just writing it down
here so if you have a bound on the
border rank of lots of independent
small matrix multiplications of r then
you get this inequality involving omega
and that's better than any individual
that's better than say an individual one
if you had just an individual bound on
the
rank or the border rank of ni
square matrix multiplication then you'd
get ni to the omega is less than r and
the fact that you get to sum these makes
the left-hand side larger and so
you can possibly get a better bound on
omega and
uh sean hunga's example
which james also talked about
proves that you in fact get
can get quite a dramatic improvement
here so this
is the this is the
outer product of a
length four vector with a like three
vector
and that by itself
takes 12
multiplications or has a border rank 12
and there's nothing more you can do with
that
but
you can pack in an additional inner
product of length six with one extra
matrix with one extra multiplication or
one extra
in
quantity in the rank
um if you would like to think of things
that way um and so the border rank of
that direct sum is 13 and that gives you
a bound
via this theorem of omega is less than
2.55 which is uh
impressive
and just like border rank played a role
in everything that follows the fact that
you can bound the exponent of matrix
multiplication by bounding lots of
independent copies uh
bounding the rank or border rank of lots
of independent uh matrix multiplications
plays a role in everything that follows
okay and so then there's the stress and
laser method
so here we start to look at the
border rank or the rank of tensors which
are no longer
so closely related to matrix
multiplication so they're not matrix
multiplication tensors per se they're
not even the direct sum of matrix
multiplication tensors
they are initially they were
tensors which have the core structure of
matrix multiplication and find structure
components that are isomorphic to matrix
multiplication in a way that is not
compatible to make the whole thing a
matrix multiplication tensor
you have to sort of play with this a
little bit to see how that could arise
i'll show you the example in just a
second but the idea is that if you have
a tensor with this structure and you
have a good bound on its quarter rank
there's a mechanism for taking high
tensor powers of it and finding lots of
copies of small matrix multiplication
tensors inside that high tensor power
and then you can get a bound via the
asymptotic summary quality on the
previous slide
here's the example that strassen used
these are again sliced so it's
parameterized by q these are slices that
i'm showing again and each of the q i
guess q slices these are two by one by
two by one uh rectangles here and then
there's cues different slices the one
you can see sort of marches
in
to the upper right corner as you go
through the different slices
uh i don't expect you to sort of be able
to discern much from looking at this
except i'll just point out that the
course structure is that of a of a
length two inner product and i've sort
of shown the blocking down here so this
is a very simple matrix multiplication
tensor and you can see the pattern in
the pink versus blue
and then the fine structure at the top
is a scalar by a row multiplied by a row
vector and the find structure here is a
column vector by a scalar
again you have to sort of stare at it
and interpret things properly but that's
those are that in that sense it fits
this uh requirement
um and i'll just
say how you can so the quarter rank of
this is is q plus one and so if you set
q to five you optimize things like q to
five you get a bound of omega is less
than 2.48
okay so then
um
we move to the copper smith wintergrad
tensor which we've heard a lot about in
virginia's talk and other said in james
talk a little bit so the border rank of
this tensor is q plus two i've stopped
drawing the pictures and i've just
written the tri-linear form um
uh it's again parameter it's
parameterized by q
and uh if you want you can sort of think
of these
things these groups of variables as
pieces i guess in virginia's language
conference with undergrad language as
well it's their blocks
and at a very high level and you know a
lot more if you saw virginia's talk you
have to choose the target proportions of
each of these pieces in a high tensor
power and when you choose that that
affects both the size and the number of
the independent matrix multiplications
that you hope to be able to ex pick out
in this high tensor power and that
affects the bound that you get so you
have to optimize these quantities
uh again in copper smith wintergrad
paper they chose q equal to six optimize
these quant things and
these poor target proportions and show
that omega is less than 2.388
and then
you know the history of recent history
and then of course the first step was
taken already in coppersmith when you
grab this paper
so you analyze the tensor power of this
you have 36 the square of that tensor
you have 36 pieces you get a slightly
better bound and then in recent work
using aided by computer search and lots
of cleverness which i'm not able to
summarize very quickly on this slide
andrew stutters and then virginia and
then francois
made further improvements by looking at
high tensor powers of this basic tensor
t as the starting point and um
and then using the machinery on top of
that to find lots of matrix
multiplications and a high tensor power
so that was sort of a whirlwind tour of
um
where things
stand now and what are the ideas that
people have used um
and then i guess the
sort of
important point to make at the end of
this is this recent result of
inventory's filness in legal
which shows that this
particular strategy is as you can kind
of infer from the way the
diminishing returns that you see in the
exponent can't beat a bound of 2.3078
and maybe a slightly general more
general thing can't even beat a band of
two point
five something i think yes
that's right correct me um so
this particular strategy sort of is as
won't get you to exponent 2 if you
believe that exponent 2 is the right
answer
um
but i do want to mention one sort of
hopeful thing that's a little bit
related sort of
um you might have sort of tangential to
this um
which is that
there's this conjecture that has to do
with a tensor which is related to the
copper smith winter grand tensor it's
i've removed the three pieces that were
in red before and i've set q the q the
parameter to be the smallest quantity
that makes it non-trivial at all so this
is a tensor that's described by this
tri-linear form it's a three by three by
three tensor which again very concretely
you can think of it as
i've drawn it out here with the three
different slices you know and it looks
very symmetric and nice
now the border rank of this sensor is
known to be four
we can ask a question about the
asymptotic rank which is just the limit
as you take high tensor powers and then
take the one over in
um and so the asymptotic rank is
somewhere between three and four we
don't know anything better than the four
that comes from just knowing that the
word rank of the actual tens of the four
but if you can prove that the asymptotic
rank is three then that gives you
exponent two
so um and that's very appealing
um and actually getting anything better
than four would i would be really
exciting
okay
you know the asymptotic rank it's maybe
hard to think about but if you at least
if you want to think of things very
concretely in terms of these slices when
you take tensor powers each of the
slices of the resulting high tensor
power has all of its ones aligned along
a diagonal because you can see these
ones all live inside these diagonals and
with certain holes
blown out of it so you can imagine maybe
using some ideas to actually study the
large um cancer power of this the
asymptotic rank uh limit or limit
the same
excuse me do you know the borderline of
the square of this
uh i know that it's at most that it's a
16 or smaller but i don't know of any
lower bound
so all these questions are around so
it's but it's not 16 you know it's 15.
no no it could be 16. no if it's 15 then
you prove it lower then you prove
something better than uh four for the
asymptote for an upper bound on the
asymptotic rank immediately so yeah so
if you can improve it for any particular
uh power yeah this asymptotic rank is
asymptotic rank or asymptotic border
rank uh well they're the same because
when you take high powers on the border
rank it coincides with rank but you can
call it a sympathetic border rank if
that makes it easier to
think about it so t squared is in
c9 so t is in c3 tensor c3 tensors c3 t
squared is in c9 tensor c9 tensor c9 and
you want to know
is it 16 or 15. yeah exactly or
something else
uh that's not like no i know
but yes of course these are all great
questions so this is i mean this is by
the way this is an improper i mean
implicit maybe in conference with a
paper and they probably asked the
question and didn't make a conjecture
but i just like to publicize this
because it seems
very appealing
and it means that the ideas in
conference with undergrad don't
necessarily sort of peter out like if
you sort of go off in this direction you
may have a way to get the exponent too
all right so i wanted to mention that
and then
in a related
um just comment before we move on to the
material about embedding into a group uh
algebras
there's so here is the tensor we were
just discussing it has rank four and
bordering four and we're interested in
the asymptotic rank here's a very
similar tensor i put in the ones that
are in
i red want to make sure i write it down
correctly
so just understand this is a symmetric
one uh
i mean this guy you want to take all of
the sum
what's the question
it's it's just this
if it if it helps you i mean we're
talking about the asymptotic rank so if
you want to take uh that tensor and then
you know pi of that tensor and pi square
that tensor and to take the direct sum
and take high powers of that and proven
to bound on that that works too
he's known the rank of t
the rank is four the border rank is four
those things are known
ah they are equal pretty cool
but the asymptotic next question
just so the whatever it is that we don't
see is zero right yeah whatever you
don't that's right these are zeros right
yeah
okay so let me say something
maybe even more tantalizing i'm not sure
so so here's the question here's the
tensor where we were asking about the
asymptotic rank here's a similar tensor
i've just put in the ones that are in
red and of course you can see this is
now has rank three very simply it's
it's a
multiplication in the group algebra over
the second group of three or whatever
you'd like to see it this is very simple
to see that the rank is three
that's what we wanted it's a similar
tensor um but how can you make use of
that for matrix multiplication well um
something called a strong uniquely
solvable puzzle which is a combinatorial
object that arose in in our work this is
uh henry myself bobby kleiner and dollar
segetty
is a combinatorial object which gives a
way of zeroing out the variables giving
many independent matrix multiplications
in high powers of this tensor which
would give exponent two if a conjecture
about this combinatorial object holds
which is fairly natural
um and so i just mentioned that because
it's another way of escaping from the
current sort of trap that virginia
talked about with coppersmith winigrad
which is that you know sort of have this
way of zeroing out variables and it's
kind of petering out and we can't go
beyond a certain thing so there's
another way that emerges in this other
setting
um
we would like to hear where the equally
solvable puzzle is
so let me since it's right here let me
do it quickly and then people
of course feel free to ask questions so
uh so i got that weird name because we
started talking thinking about something
called the uniquely solvable puzzle
which is this array of zeros ones and
twos
with w and n rows
and what do you want for it to be
uniquely solvable you would like it to
be the case that any t anytime you take
imagine these zeros ones and twos is
representing physical puzzle pieces okay
and anytime you take a zero piece from
one row a one piece from another row and
a two piece from the third row and put
them on top of one another
you'd like there to be an overlap of
some overlap so either two or three
cells that coincide uh somewhere so that
there's no way to sort of so the puzzle
can be assembled in the way that's
represented here but if you take a zero
one and a two piece in from in some
other way in an unintended way you can't
assemble them without the pieces not
fitting together that's the
analogy with physical puzzles
and then a strong uniquely solvable
puzzle would be such a array of zeros
ones and twos again in which every
unintended way of assembling pieces have
it has an overlap of
exactly two in some cell so
an overlap of just a green and a just a
yellow and a green or just a green and a
purple or just
yellow some cell and you can have lots
of other overlaps elsewhere
this is a dumb question but what does
unintended mean well unintended means
there's existing rows so you can put a
zero from this row together with the one
piece from this row together with the
two piece from this row and it fits
together with that overlap because
that's the way it started out
think of it as a puzzle
like a physical puzzle uh there's an
intended way of assembling it that's the
way it comes when you buy it in the
store and every other way of putting it
together you
have a collision
that's what we're trying to go for here
so you'd like that so strong
means that you should have exactly two
in one cell and it's not too hard to see
okay so what are you trying to do here
for a fixed w you'd like to have as many
rows as possible
it's not too hard to see that you can
enlarge as these quantities get large
you can assume that the rows have equal
numbers of zeros ones and twos and so
and you can also see that you can't have
a repeated piece if you have a zero
piece that's the same as some other zero
piece that already violates the property
so a natural upper simple upper bound is
dub w the number of the width uh choose
w over three
uh many different rows because you can't
have repeated pieces in copper smith
vinaigrette it's implicit in copper
smith wintergrad that you can construct
uniquely solvable puzzles with
approximately that number of rows the
conjecture is that you can construct
strong uniquely solvable puzzles with
roughly the same number of rows and if
you can you get exponent 2
via that tensor and zeroing out that
tension
okay so uh all right so i so those are
two
ways that you could get exponent two
uh i just wanted to mention them because
they're sort of an outgrowth of the
coppersmith undergrad approach um i'd
like to talk about something different
now uh but um
yes
i did with henry when i arrived on
sunday and we got this
episode
for all of us at this point but anyway
um
okay so what's happening what's
happening with all of the um stuff that
we've seen so far again this is my
perspective um
the approaches have the following common
features they you bound the border rank
of some um small tensor by hand
or perhaps you have an algebraic
geometric interpretation of it but still
it's like this little tensor with side
length five or six or maybe seven and
you kind of have some very um
almost miraculously low border rank for
that tensor
and then you get an asymptotic bound on
the matrix multiplication exponent from
looking at high tensor powers of it and
having some machinery that goes that
looks in high tensor powers and picks
out lots of independent matrix
multiplication but you have to start
with that little
starting point and we don't have we're
running out of starting points we have
the copper synthetic grad tensor we've
run that into the ground uh we have some
other examples but they're sort of
limited
also high tensor powers are hard to
analyze and we have some very beautiful
machinery but i'm not sure there are new
ideas
it's not that the universe is starting
tensors is
limited it's our knowledge of them
perhaps uh yeah or or um that's right
certainly
they have to be useful together with
some machinery for matrix multiplication
so that little things
okay so
another approach and i'd like to sort of
draw a contrast between that approach
where you have this these
specific starting tensors with the sort
of ass more asymptotic approach that
i've tried to describe now um which is
something that henry and i started and
worked with other people as well
to develop so there's major
complications groups and
association schemes
okay so the general approach says we
initially uh envisioned it and then
generalized in 2012 uh is uh
it's a very in certain way it's a
computer science type approach if you
will we're doing a reduction or an
embedding we're going to take n by n
matrix multiplication and try to embed
it into semi-simple algebra
multiplication for some choice of some
example algebra which i'll
say something in a minute for our
purposes of this talk semi-simple just
means that the algebra multiplication is
isomorphic to block diagonal matrix
multiplication picture here
okay
uh that is to say the algebra is
isomorphic to the
product of lots of matrix several matrix
algebras
now the hope in doing this and i'll try
to illustrate this on the next slides
is that the algebra comes equipped with
some kind of nice basis
which has a combinatorial or algebraic
structure
where we can describe
what we need for there to be an
embedding
in those combinatorial algebraic terms
and make progress in that domain and
then apply the fact that this
is actually reducing to a block diagonal
matrix multiplication to
hopefully reduce a large matrix
multiplication to lots of smaller matrix
multiplications and this gives you a
natural algorithmic strategy if you
recurse and you have the right
relationship between the sizes then you
can get an upper bound you get a good
algorithm or an upper bound on omega
i'll just comment here because we'll use
it later that if the algebra is
commutative then those blocks are all
one by one blocks it's just diagonal
matrix multiplication that's great
because we don't really have recursion
we just reduced to lots of lots of
scalar multiplication
okay so we started with group algebras
and i'm going to start with that as a
way of illustrating what i mean by nice
basis and how this embedding works so we
have a finite group the group algebra cg
has elements which are formal linear
combinations of group elements there's
the multiplication it's some kind of
convolution you know this this is the
structure
and you guys are the character degrees
or the dimensions of the irreducible
representations okay and the main the
only point i really need to make this
audience on the slide is that the group
elements in this case are the nice bases
uh by which i mean this uh
if you're interested in what it takes to
embed a matrix multiplication into a
group algebra matrix multiplication
tensor into the group algebra
multiplication tensor you can express
you can describe it in this rather nice
and rather nice terms that just talk
about the group
so in order to embed a
matrix multiplication
into group algebra you are seeking three
subgroups x y and z of a group g that
satisfy this triple product property
which is pretty natural which is says
that if you take an element from the
first subgroup uh an element to the
second subgroup and an element of the
third subgroup and multiply them and get
the identity that can happen only in the
trivial way x equals y equals z equals
1.
and if you have this it gives you an
embedding
i have to make one small change so
instead of subgroups we'd like to allow
subsets and i'm choosing x y and z now
from the quotients
of that set with the right quotients
let's say of the elements of x y and z
okay
question sets that we'll look at are
very close to subgroups so this
shouldn't disturb you too much
that's the official definition and
here's the way you perform the embedding
you take the entries of
a and you take the you index them by
elements of the set x and y so the x y
element of a entry of a is the
coefficient on the group element x y
inverse
the y z
entry of b is the coefficient on the y z
inverse group element so that gives you
two group algebra elements and if you
multiply them you find that in their
product the x z
the coefficient on xz inverse the group
element in their product is in fact the
x z entry in the result matrix and
that's just a simple manipulation to see
right now
okay
so that's an appealing way to try to
find ways of embedding matrix
multiplication you need this you're
trying to find these sub
sets that are close to subgroups of g
that satisfy this nice property
and then what do you get out of this of
course it depends on the size of those
subsets and the size of the group and
all those sorts of things so here's a
way of seeing uh what happens so the
embedding
of matrix multiplication and the
structure of the group algebra which
looks like this yields some bound on the
number of multiplications that are
required to actually carry out the
matrix multiplication the number of
multiplications is the same
thing as rank if we're talking about the
ten standalone tensors
so what does it take to do this
multiplication in the group algebra in
this nice structure the group algebra
well
there are the these blocks have size d i
we could use standard matrix
multiplication and use d i sum the d i
cubed multiplications in there so that's
a reduction from n by n matrix
multiplication to the sum of d i cubed
um but of course
you shouldn't be satisfied with that
because that's not the best thing we can
do we should use maybe stressence
or something better or cover some
thundergrad but and we have a name for
the best one it's called sum of bi to
omega whatever omega is
okay so that's the actual quantity that
we'll use in the proofs but just for uh
sort of a to think about it at first
let's just notice that omega's at least
two so it takes at least the sum of the
di squared multiplications to do this
product and the sum of the di squares is
the size of g
so this already sort of sets us
sets up a challenge which is that if we
hope to get exponent two by this
embedding which we do
um
we need to be able to embed k by k
matrix multiplication into a group of
size
that's pretty small like approximately k
squared
okay because if you sort of think about
what's the conclusion of this
if you
uh
get a group of size about k squared here
then if your group has size larger than
k squared you can't even hope for a
bound which is going to give you
uh approaching two okay and then there's
an interaction with what the actual
character degrees are but for the moment
we can think of this as our role i hope
that makes some sense
that's just a that's just a question
about groups
can you embed major can you find this
triple product property
in a group of size about k squared where
each of the x y and z have size about k
i wrote that here whoops i want to make
a comment first which is that a simple
pigeonhole argument shows that you can't
use availing groups to get
at all
k cubed is
which corresponds to exponent 3.
okay so we have to use non-abelian
groups which in some ways is satisfying
it feels like it should be complicated
certainly and uh so in fact in the early
paper we showed that you can embed k by
k matrix multiplication
of about k squared it's a symmetric
group
and um
i'd like to show you the example and
then i think i'm going to skip the proof
in favor of moving towards the more
recent stuff but here's the example
because it's it's appealing and you can
signify once you see it it's an exercise
to prove that these satisfy the triple
product property so we're looking for
three sub sets in fact in this case will
be subgroups which is nice in sn which
have about the square root of the size
of the group size
that satisfy this triple product
property and here's a here's the
description of them so we think of sn
acting on n objects in this triangular
array
and then there's one subgroup which
moves things around only inside the red
boxes
another one which moves things around
all the inside green boxes and third
that moves things around over there and
each of those if you do the computation
has size
each of those subgroups has size about
the square root of the size of the whole
group
and you can prove that they satisfy the
triple product properties which is to
say that if you first move things around
via one an element of the red subgroup
and then via an element to the green
subgroup and then via an element of the
blue subgroup and if you get back to the
identity then none of each each of those
three elements had to be the identity
that's a
that's an exercise
so there's there's a visual proof which
i some of you have seen before it's
uh
okay so but what do we get from this so
it almost sounded like we get exponent
two from this that was our goal to get
the embedding into a small enough group
unfortunately you know what really
matters of course is the size of those
blocks and in this case unfortunately uh
the maximum character degree is actually
even larger than the size of the
matrices into which you which you are
embedding so actually you make your
embedded n by n matrix multiplication
you reduced it to a bunch of matrix
multiplications one of which was even
larger so that's not progress
so so the symmetric group is nowhere in
this construction this metric group is
no good for that reason
so here's the real theorem in a group
that supports k by k matrix
multiplication via this embedding if you
have character degrees d1 etc d1 d2 d3
uh you get this bound so and that's very
natural right it says the
uh you can do k by k matrix
multiplication
that the number of multiplications
needed to do k by k matrix
multiplication is upper bounded by the
number of multiplications that you need
to do all of these block multiplications
d1 d2b
so you can see that both the character
degrees and the embedding play a role in
what kind of
bound on omega you might get out of this
uh so
just as a very sort of a
to say to make something a little bit
more concrete like what should you be
aiming for here's one way that you could
get exponent two in this strategy if you
can embed
k by k matrix multiplication into a
group so if you can embed in the way
that we managed to do on the previous
slide where the size of these three
subgroups is about the square root of
the size of the group it's approaching
the size of the square root of the size
of the group is the we in fact have a
family of groups and the family of
values
you can do that and you can manage that
in a group whose maximum character
degree
is bounded away from the square root of
the size of the group by some constant
epsilon in the exponent like that
then you get exponent 2.
okay
so simple manipulation there to
help prove that okay
and so
um
this is something we've tried for a long
time uh and um but
there are lots of possibilities there's
lots of groups out there there's lots of
possibilities and i just mentioned this
one a good candidate family for this
would be sln q or any other linear
groups where you fix the dimension and
let q grow so that gives you a family of
groups the fact that the dimensions
fixed gives you this
second position here the largest
character degree is bounded away from
the square root of the size of the group
by
epsilon and the exponent
and if you can manage in that family of
groups to satisfy the triple product
property find three subsets or subgroups
even that approach the square root of
the size of the group and satisfy the
triple product property then you get
exponent two
um and i just since there's enough
algorithm for audience um i don't know
if that's an adjective
audience um this is some construction we
had in the early paper which we don't
know how to do something with because it
fails in a couple of ways but it seems
very appealing in sln r
uh with n growing and of course we
needed it in the finite field setting
and this is with r the three subgroups
that satisfy the triple product property
are the upper triangular uh uh lower
triangular and the special orthogonal
group and each of those has about half
the dimension
now this is in the weed
half the dimension of the containing
group
and so they set their everything works
in one way but of course we needed this
defining characteristic and for fixed
standards maybe this requires
a different construction uh in srn
perfect
so you cannot change from r to cube
because there's no then the the way that
this argument works it really uses
characteristic zero but
so i don't think i mean we tried hard
and actually i don't think there's a way
to sort of tweak this to make it work
but i hope that it maybe suggests that
there's something that could be done in
linear groups it was always the place
where we felt
it ought to work
nicely for the fact that the
character degree is the largest
characteristic
so that's in groups
now what did we actually do in groups so
in the 2005 paper we actually found
wreath product groups that don't suffer
from this problem that the largest
character degree messes things up
we actually make progress
so in those groups we got bounds of 2.48
and with a different construction 2.41
the key part of the construction
unfortunately turns out to be
combinatorial we sort of we didn't want
that to happen but that sort of emerged
in the way that we were able to finally
construct these things
and there are two conjectures that arose
a network that would imply omega is
equal to two one of them was the strong
uniquely solvable puzzle conjecture
which i described before that actually
merges naturally in the group setting
and then you can interpret it also with
respect to the tensor that i described
on that slime
so you can prove quite good bounds using
the group approach which is encouraging
but we we don't know how to go beyond
these
um and the main disadvantage from
playing with this for a long time is
that
non-trivial results require non-abelian
groups
and there seems to be a tension between
being able to find a triple product
property construction packing in a
matrix multiplication and having small
character degrees so it seems to work
anytime you get a good construction then
you go check the character degrees you
find that they're large
this one family of groups that's kind of
carefully engineered
so this is us this is always this has
been a struggle
um
now
and this is the struggle that we hope to
alleviate by generalizing and i'd like
to describe this generalization to
association schemes now
or more generally just semi-simple
azures
so here's the setting very generally now
right so not group algebra anymore but a
general
algebra which has a basis e1 through er
that's going to be the nice basis that i
hope to be able to exploit
in general the algebra is described by
these structure constants lambda i j k
and tell it how you multiply e i and e j
and what do i mean by embedding a matrix
multiplication tensor into this algebra
it's actually the following here's the
structural tensor of the algebra
multiplication it happens to be the
tensor which is populated by the entries
lambda i j k
and embedding a matrix multiplication
tensor simply means that you can
actually find a copy of a matrix
multiplication tensor sitting inside it
now there's a little asterisk there
because of the following
observation
here's again the matrix multiplication
tensor all of its entries are zero or
one
the most natural embedding which sort of
finds that same pattern of zeros and
non-zeros uh
bounds a ten gives you a bound on the
rank of a tensor which is
what we might call a weighted matrix
multiplication tensor it has these
lambda ijks there and they might not be
ones
so we can look for the same pattern of
zeros and ones um but in a general
semi-simple algebra these lenses are all
sorts of crazy numbers
and so a natural thing is to get a bound
on that
group algebra happens to be nice in the
sense that those lambda ijks are always
zero or one so we never had to confront
this problem
but this is an actual problem right so
this is a if we get a bound on the
rank of this tensor
doesn't mean anything about the rank of
this tensor
and i just point out that you can't
there's something like n cubed different
parameters here so you can't just clear
them by
multiplying or dividing entries of the
initial matrices
and the result matrix to sort of cancel
these because there's only order n
squared such entries okay so there's no
easy way to just give
skate rescale things so that these
things these weights go away
and we defined this question this notion
of s rank or support rank so we're
interested then in the minimum rank of a
tensor with the same support as t that's
the thing that we can actually bound
when you do this general embedding into
a semi-simple algebra and the question
that i asked on the previous slide in
those terms in this in these terms is
does an upper bound on the s rank of
matrix multiplication tensor imply an
upper bound on the ordinary range
because it assumes that boundaries are
positive or any side just non-zero
yeah
um and if you can do something when
they're positive that would also be
interesting but we have an answer to
this question but i just want to point
out like so here's a very concrete thing
here's a two by two matrix
multiplication i wrote out the
expressions that all the results uh
increase
so let's both have the result matrix uh
so we know by strassen's algorithm that
you can have a clever way of doing this
with seven multiplications
what if i told you that you could do it
with six multiplications but it
you just this piece here gets multiplied
by two
that's
so you can't it rid of it you can't just
divide a 2 2 by 2 because then it messes
up what this one you can't divide b 2 2
by 2 because it messes up something else
right so there's no easy way to get rid
of the two
and push it around
so does that give you anything for
matrix multiplication it's an
interesting question
and in fact estrang can be much smaller
than rank here here's an example just
with matrices so here's a rank n matrix
where you can express it as the linear
combination of two rank one matrices if
you only care about getting the support
right so this is
you can see that if you take the
difference of these two things then the
diagonal becomes zeros and everything
else is non-zero
okay so maybe just to make it
dramatic maybe it's easy to show that
the s rank of n by n matrix
multiplication is n squared maybe you
can just do that quickly
yes but does that give you anything so
what we actually so you can define the s
rank version of the exponent of matrix
multiplication just like you could
define the uh exponent of matrix
ordinary one
um the theorem we proved in the paper
is that actually the s-rank does give
you an upper bound on omega so omega's
there's the inequality omega is less
than three oh my guess if that's minus
two over two and the important thing to
notice here is that if omega sub s is
two plus epsilon so you're getting close
to two then the boundary omega you get
is two plus and then a fifty percent
penalty on multiplying
the other important thing of course is
that if you get omega sub s to go to two
then omega also goes to two okay so
there's a viable approach if you're
trying to get shoot for x moment two
uh and the proof idea oops and the proof
idea is i'm gonna skip to the interest
of time but this tells you that you can
think about s rank in place of rank if
you're trying to get exponent 2.
and that opens up the possibility of
really using general semi-simple
algebras and here the last part i wanted
to talk about in the last few minutes is
the
family of semi-simple algebras which are
based on association schemes or coherent
configurations which are
basically referred to as described as
group theory without groups so what is a
coherent configuration very quickly
it's a set of points
and a partition of pairs of points into
classes r1 through r little r that's the
rank
and they satisfy some axioms the first
one and is the diagonal is the universal
classes that's not so interesting second
one is that there's a dual relationship
so for every class you have a class
consisting of the pairs reverse that's
not the most interesting one and the
last one of course is the important one
which says that if you have um
there are these
intersection numbers
p i j k so if you're interested in the
number of z
that um have the relationship with x
that they're in class i
and the relationship with y that they're
in class j
um then that number
depends only on the class in which x y
lives okay so this is independent of the
particular choice of x1
i have this triangular picture the
number of z that are just inside if you
think would be distances distance i from
x distance j from y depends only on the
distance between x and y
and so and if there's one class this is
called an association scheme if the pijs
are
symmetric in this way then this is a
commutative uh
association scheme
and i just want to point out so there's
lots of examples there's of course a
huge topic but there are examples that
come from the capture aspects of coding
theory there's something called a
hamming scheme distance regular graphs
are in some ways you can think of them
as defined as association scheme where
the points are vertices and the classes
are determined by a distance in the
graph metric
every finite group gives rise to an
association scheme um uh because the
classes are just things that are uh
related to elements that are related by
translation by the particular group
element so where did these things first
arise in this area what do they first
arise in i mean
the somebody made up this the henry can
answer that's probably better than that
i mean did you guys think that no no
this is no this is a this is a huge
topic in algebraic combinatorics that
captures lots of things and generalizes
lots of things and it's an object of
study in its own right and it's
definitely not our invention there are
some papers of hitman from the 60s that
started this i think
so they generalize groups which is
important for for thinking about this
particular approach this particular
application
you can capture group actions and these
are called shurian associations coherent
configurations if you have a group that
acts on the setx you can take the
classes to the to be the orbits of the
diagonal group action on x squared and
that gives you a huge a variety of um
association games or coherent
configurations um
that have an algebraic flavor to them
there's one particular one that's
interesting to us it's called the group
scheme if you have g cross g acting on g
via this uh sort of almost like a
conjugation then the orbits then the
classes turn out to be pairs which have
the property that uh that well that are
described by the conjugacy classes and
this is always a commutative association
theme and you'll see that commutative
plays an important role in just a second
and there's an associated algebra that
you should think of as the analog of the
group algebra
again this is a coherent configuration
you have points in the association
classes which partition the pairs of
points
and for every such class you can just
put down you can describe a matrix a
zero one matrix which just tells you
which points belong to that given class
with its ones
and then these matrices form an algebra
they generate a semi-simple algebra this
follows from the three axioms of what it
means to be a coherent configuration for
example third axiom the important one uh
implies that you're closed um and i'll
just point out that if the coherent
configuration was the one that i
described in the previous slide that
comes from a group then this is just the
group algebra so this is all a
generalization of the setting that we
saw previously
okay so just like the group algebra
setting uh give gave you i tried to make
this point about there being a nice
basis
that gave you the triple product
property that was the way you could
think of trying to embed matrix
multiplication into this algebra
with an adjacent with the adjacency
algebras of coherent configurations the
nice basis yield something that's a
little bit harder to describe it's a
triangle condition it says you should
name a bunch of the
association classes
these maps alpha beta and gamma and they
should look like they should be able to
form this triangle where the points
coincide if and only if i equals i prime
j equals j prime and k equals k so
that's something you have to look at a
little bit more than the triple product
property but it's something similar
and that's what it means to embed matrix
multiplication into a um
configuration
and there's a nice how much am i over
time
okay so there's a nicer uh description
which i won't go into in the case of
sharing coherent configurations that
also sort of
something that you can imagine working
with uh now the main point i want to
make in the last two slides uh is this
just a generalization for generalization
sake that's a valid um
criticism potentially
so the key thing is that in the group
framework the non-commutative
setting was necessary you had to have
non-appealing groups to get anything
non-trivial and then you had to confront
the representation theory and the
character degrees and as i said there
was this tension where they tended to
pop up and be too large and rock your
constructions
there was the theorem and you can see
that that the bound on the rank that you
get depends both on the size of the
group and the largest character degree
and so that's that was the part that we
were struggling with
in the and we thought sort of that the
same sort of thing might happen with
coherent configurations or association
schemes maybe you can just prove that
non-abelian non-commutative is necessary
in the same kind of simple way and you'd
be faced with the same kind of problems
but you had a more general class of
objects but we were surprised to find
that in this framework commutative
suffices so actually we have
you can import the constructions that we
had in the old setting to prove that
even in the commutative
coherent setting of coherent
configurations you can get non-trivial
bounds on omega and in fact the
conjectures from the old setting via the
same sort of translation would imply
omega this is again my ghost of s
because we're talking about this more
general setting would be is two and all
of these things happen in commutative in
fact sure in coherent configurations and
even in group schemes and even in
symmetric schemes if you work at it so
really simple
versions of these objects these coherent
configurations and association schemes
suffice to prove non-trivial bounds on
omega and under conjectures get all the
way to exponent two so you don't have to
concern yourself with the representation
theory of the algebras you can work in
very similar versus logic so the so in
the end
all you need to do is embed
and band matrix multiplication
into a commutative coherent
configuration of rank about n squared
and if you do that you get exponent 2
with no further work
so that seems appealing that's something
that we're kind of familiar we want to
take as large an object as possible and
kind of
reduce it to a smaller object as
possible
and then you don't have to think about
any algebra on the side
uh so that so that's that's what i want
to leave you with of course we haven't
been able to do that
so there's no easy way that i know of
but there's lots of things to think
about so i'll just leave you with these
possibly open problems there's lots of
open problems but find a construction a
new framework that proves bounds that
doesn't seem to rely on the sort of
importing the old ones that was sort of
our first attempt and but we need to get
past that and we need a new idea
is the quarter rank of that two two two
six we don't know whether it's six or
seven
question
and uh in the general question from the
previous slide embed a large matrix
multiplication instance into a
commutative coherent configuration of
small rank and if you can do that you
get x.2
thanks very much
any questions
so
why do you think the exponent is two
right
i mean
the other numbers don't
make sense
why are there any black people why do
you ever i mean it shouldn't be it's
certainly not 2.376
whatever right
i mean it could be i mean but it doesn't
seem like that's the right answer two
and a third i've often said
maybe is plausible but i don't i mean
it's uh
any of these things are just situations
yes so your one slide showed that the
air strength of this transfer is
at most six right and then the border
ring can drop so that you are already
working when your slides show there was
you had this formula with six only oh
that was imagine that you could prove
that that was that yeah i wish i could i
wish it were actually uh
so do you get the same exponent for the
motor s ring and the s rank no there's
that lot well so the way we know to
relate them there's this loss this 50
percent loss so if you prove a bound on
the border
um
sorry the oh bordering versus oh yes
makes no sense because the generic
tensor has s rank one
so every tensor has border order s rank
one
you can throw in the epsilons and if
that helps you but by the time you apply
the machinery to get a bound on omega
from the s rank you're going to high
tens of cards anyway so the difference
because i mean if it helps for thinking
about a small example that it's a
legitimate thing to do although that it
makes the
same
work
yes you said in this new approach there
is no representation
anymore so i want maybe you can give a
higher level explanation when you
approach you have
you embed the matrix multiplication in
the group algebra and then there is this
theorem by weatherburn that is yeah so
this
they're the same strategies it just
means that if you're thinking about
using groups and you would like to use
the triple product property as your
mechanism for describing the embedding
you have to use non-appealing groups
and then that means that when you
first you know sort of the strategy is
first you find the embedding then you
look at the group and you look at the
representations and you hope they're
small
so this is two-piece thing and they
interact in ways that seem unpleasant
generally from our experience
in this setting in principle
you can do the same thing there's a
different expression there's a different
sort of a formulation of what it means
to embed a matrix multiplication
instance into an association scheme it's
a little harder to understand than the
triple product property you can try to
do it so anyway so that's a
combinatorial question you kind of play
with association schemes when you try to
do that embedding
but in principle you can do it with a
commutative association scheme and then
you're done if you embed a large matrix
multiplication instance into a small
rank association scheme you're done rank
just means the dimension of the algebra
so you're not you don't have to study
representations because it's commutative
and so that seems to remove a big
stumbling block although we now actually
have to find out that
it's just a reduction now that you're
looking for the question is what does it
mean that then
right that's right and i unfortunately
went quickly through those slides
there's an expression that's sort of
like the triple product property
formulation for groups that says what it
means to embed into an association
so you can
you can
follow that same sort of program
unfortunately we don't have good
examples that sort of escape from what
we already know how to do with groups
but that's probably just
lack of
very combinatorial but there's still a
notion of algebra there but otherwise
it's combinatorial yeah that's right
right so association schemes i mean
there's they're algebraic but they're
also combinatorial and
then the embedding is a combinatorial
question i think associates seems very
comfortable they're really a subject to
contract towards society yeah this is
right okay
general algebras
if i mean usually if you
reduce complexity problems to come in a
turret so all you're doing is creating
more headaches rather than less
it's possible
especially for people
i mean i would say we maybe the thing if
so that's your perspective maybe you
should think of that slide where we had
the suggestion that maybe you could work
in in linear groups and get the group
embedding so that was sort of our
initial hope when we had this idea of
using group algorithms we're like oh we
can use algebra and representation
theory will do lots of work for us and
if we just had this embedding into the
appropriate kind of group with character
degrees that were bounded away from a
half then everything would work out and
there would be a lot of algebra
in the machinery at least
unfortunately that hasn't worked but
maybe it will have you tried sort of
deforming algebras i mean that's the
topic that came up that's uh
but that's kind of something that
i think because then then you have more
flexibility right you have families
you can hope to cross some barrier
without you know by using some family
and limiting
yeah that's a good idea
when some families have elders that can
be deformed the symmetric groups you get
hectic algebras but they have the same
representation theory as the groups
yeah but the analysis of their border
rank might be easier
in the family than just as you know so
the symmetric group is a headache right
but if you have this family of objects
which visually look different even
though secretly their representation
theory is the same
if their visual appearance makes their
the
getting an upper bound on the border
rank more tractable
then that could be a
useful thing
any final questions
okay well it's thanks again